so we've been talking about curvature
and this means uh you've got some sort
of parametric curve they might think of
as parameterized by a vector-valued
function s of t
and curvature is supposed to measure
just how much this curve actually curves
so here it's curving quite a bit
curvature should be high but here it's
you know relatively straight so
curvature should be low
and i uh i brought up in the last video
this pretty complicated formula and to
remind you of the circumstances
i was saying that curvature denoted with
this little kappa
is typically calculated as the
derivative of the unit tangent vector
function so we'll think of some kind of
uh function that gives unit tangent
vectors at every single point so you
know just a vector with a length of 1
lying tangent to the curve and that's
going to be some kind of function of the
same parameter so big t for unit tangent
vector little t for the parameter
hopefully that's not too confusing
then we're taking the derivative of this
not with respect to t the parameter but
with respect to arc length s
and by arc length i mean if you take a
tiny step along the curve and consider
this to be of size d s so s typically
denotes length along a curve this will
be a tiny change in length you're
wondering how much that unit tangent
vector changes
and specifically what i mean by that if
you kind of imagine tangent vectors off
sitting in their own space somewhere
where each one of them has unit length
so they're all
just kind of of the same length and
let's say they're all stemming from the
same point so rather than drawing them
stemming from the curve to show that
they're tangent i just want to show them
in their own space the derivative the
change in that tangent vector would be
some
some other vector that tells you how you
move from one to the other kind of tells
you how much it's turning so the
curvature itself is given not by that
vector because this this would be a
vector quantity but by the absolute
value of it
and i said in the last video
that it turns out that this quantity
when you work it out for a vector-valued
function
with components
with components x of t
x of t and y of t
that it happens to equal
this complicated formula and what i'm
going to do here i'm going to break it
down and show why this formula isn't
actually all that random it's actually
kind of sensible as a description for
how much the curve really curves at a
point so let's start by looking at the
numerator here this x prime of t first
derivative of the first component times
the second derivative of the second
component minus and then kind of
symmetrically y prime times x double
prime
you might be able to recognize this as a
certain cross product
so the cross product if we take x prime
y prime
and these are still functions of t
as a vector
crossed with the vector containing the
double primes and if you're unfamiliar
with cross products or you're feeling a
little shaky and you kind of want to
review now would be a good time to pause
the video take a look at the cross
product videos and remind yourself both
of how to compute it and what the
underlying intuition is
because the way that we compute a cross
product like this is you take the
components in the diagonal here you know
that rightward diagonal and multiply
them together that's where you get your
x prime
y double prime
and then you subtract off the components
in the other diagonal you know it kind
of feels like a determinant
x double prime
times y prime
but the way that you interpret this
vector well i'll get to the
interpretation in just a moment first
first let me kind of write out what this
is in terms of our function s this first
vector is just the first derivative of s
so that's s prime of t
the first derivative of s and we're
crossing that with this one which is the
second derivative
vector-valued derivative but the second
derivative
of s
so
before we before we do anything else
let's just start to think about what do
both of these vectors mean how do you
interpret the s prime and the s double
prime and i'll go ahead and
give ourselves a little bit of room here
so i'll draw the curve again we're on
our x y plane and you have some kind of
curve
the function s itself is giving vectors
whose tips
trace out this curve
right as t changes the tips of these
vectors trace out the curve
and now the first derivative that first
derivative vector s prime of t
is telling you
how that tip should move to go along the
curve as you go from one s vector to
another s vector what direction should
that tip move and what this means is
that at every given point
when you kind of do this in a limiting
fashion and you you only look at
infinitesimal changes in the original
vector you always get some kind of
tangent vector right so all of these are
tangent vectors not necessarily unit you
know you might have like a very long
tangent vector to indicate that you're
traveling very quickly across that space
and now how would you think about the
second derivative vector here
s double prime of t
well the way to do that i i like to
think of all of the tangent vectors than
just kind of living in their own space
right if this here is representing
s of t
i just want to look in isolation at what
s
prime of t looks like
so each one of those vectors you know
maybe this first one is just this very
long gargantuan indicating you're going
very quickly and then after that you've
got something else here
maybe it's pointing a little bit down
and you're kind of thinking about how
all of these derivative vectors change
but i want them all rooted at the same
point i'll just see what happens when
they're all rooted at the origin because
that
that gives us a way to think about what
changing the vector should look like so
in particular as you're moving from this
vector to this one the tip should be
kind of moving in this direction right
so this second derivative value is going
to tell us how the tip of the first
derivative should move and then
similarly over here tells us how the tip
of that should move
and just as an example and kind of a
hint as to why this has something to do
with curvature
if you have
a curve that turns very sharply
turns very sharply you would have
you know a tangent vector that starts by
pointing up and to the right and then
very quickly is pointing down down into
the right so if they were off you know
we kind of draw them on their own rooted
in their own location
you can maybe see how the second
derivative vector is telling it to turn
somehow in that direction and if you you
know if you capture not just those two
but infinitesimally what's going on as
you move from one to the next you're
going to get this kind of turning motion
for all of these guys so the second
derivative vector would be pulling
perpendicular perpendicular to that
first derivative vector as a way of
telling it to turn
so just to draw that on its own if you
have a first derivative vector and then
the second derivative vector is
perpendicular to it it's telling it how
it should turn in some way but if it was
you know let's say it was not purely
perpendicular but it was also pointing
against it would be telling that that
vector that first derivative vector to
shrink in some way so that would be an
indication that not only is it turning
but it's getting smaller meaning the the
trajectory based on s is probably
slowing down and if it was
kind of turning it but also pointing
away that would mean it's telling the
first derivative vector to grow so not
only should you be turning on your curve
but you should also be speeding up but
the case we care about most is we're
just trying to measure how how
perpendicular it is right
and this is where the cross product
becomes it comes in because if you think
about how you interpret that cross
product
how you interpret the cross product it's
basically the area if you kind of take
these two vectors tip to tail as they
are
and think about the parallelogram that
they trace out let's see so this blue
dotted line should be parallel to the
blue vector
the area of this
of this traced out parallelogram for
each of them that's what tells you
that's how you interpret the cross
product the cross product between s
prime
and s double prime so this cross product
by giving you that area is kind of a
measure of just how perpendicular these
vectors are right because if one of them
if they point very much in the same
direction right and they're only
slightly perpendicular that means that
the parallelogram they trace they trace
out
is going to have a very small area it's
going to be a smaller area in comparison
so with that
i don't want this video to run too long
so i'm going to call it in here but then
i'll just continue on in the next one
through the same line of reasoning to
build to our to our original formula